today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block pizza is a
fanatical or fantastic that's what I
meant
I picked the wrong if it's a finesse
fantastical there we go let's teamwork
baby
it's a fantastical pizza place pizza is
something that's round but people cut it
in a different shape to enjoy it and
just knowing the fact that something
goes through two different shapes before
it hits your mouth I mean that's it's a
real shape-shifting type of treat and
that is gray block pizza thank you guys
for being here with me today I got this
here that I got a sack of bells from
home somebody sent me this you know when
I was growing up we grew up by Larson's
they had up
it was jingle bell outlet and they made
I think they had a sign out front it
used to put up a counter of how many
jingle bells they'd made over the years
you know and I swear to God they
probably I think at one point it got up
to you know I want to say almost 90,000
JB's had rolled out of that joint and
and now it's only because they the
person putting the sign putting the sign
and adjusting the number they just
[ __ ] gave up or they you know they
were afflicted with on education or miss
education or bad math you know if
somebody has bad math they're kind of
they can only do so much you know
somebody has bad math eight you know
once you get past you know 12 or 13
items they don't know what the hell's
going on but this person you know it was
like a Burger King they used to have a
sign at Burger King where every time
they you know sell at Burger they put
another one outside you know over you
know 70,000 served or whatever and
larsson's this Jingle Bell outlet right
next to us they had a basis I think
served over 70,000 or something or
whatever they had done and then the sign
maker [ __ ] gave up or
who knows what happened to him I mean
that's a lot of math for somebody low
you know a local person to do when you
get up over 70,000 and especially to
count the bells and know how many bells
were made you know it's uh I mean that
man was really the Frederick Douglas of
our area in a lot of ways but this is a
sack somebody sent me a sack of those
beautiful old Larsen's bells right there
and the fun thing about growing up you
know but next to the outlet you'd be
outside
you know you'd fall in a hole or
something outside and next thing you'd
hear it is because the hole would be
filled with you know with belt with
jingle bell and so sometime you fall
down you fall on a couple bells and you
get a little you think you're bout to
hurt yourself but you get a little of
that so it's kind of fascinating when uh
when you have that you when you have the
magic of jingle bells around all types
of things can occur you know we had a um
we had a neighbor and he he you know he
will it's a little bit sad but he shot
himself in the face on accident and most
people do there's two types of people
sorry
emails open I've noticed there's two
types of people in a universe there are
people that shoot themselves in the face
purposefully and people that shoot
themselves in the face on accident and
what had happened was he was looking in
the you know a lot of families if they
have Christmas gifts they hide him in
the closet and he was in there looking
for him right well they had a shotgun in
there and the of the shotgun was the
barrel was facing up right well a jingle
bell had rolled off one of the shelves
from the Christmas gifts internet
shotgun
so anyhow he's in there looking for
something he sets off the shotgun it
fires a JB right up into his cheek
so he had a lot he had a jingle bell
lodged in his cheek as long as I knew
and they called him tink actually and uh
and decent guy I'll say this kind of an
[ __ ] really but the thing was uh the
one redeeming quality he had about
himself was every now and then even
though he'd be pissed off at you or he'd
be furious sometime you'd get a little
bit of that out of him whenever even
when he was angry and it would set you
at peace you know there's something
powerful about hearing a jingle bell you
know there's something really really I
think powerful about it
[Music]
there's something powerful about hearing
a jingle bell in there and this is one
time of year when you know you can use a
jingle bell and it's not creepy really
it's not uh you know you're not a bad
guy
if you roll up somewhere with a couple
of jingle bells rockin happy December to
you and to myself as well I'll say that
today is Monday December 10th
this episode is up later than usual I
took a I took it some time off yesterday
you know I was I was tired I was tired
and I'm not tired at the moment and I'm
grateful to be here with you guys today
I got back from Lexington Kentucky and I
have this shirt on right here and it's
straight out of Lexington and who gave
me this shirt was my friend Jared
Lorenzen and he's a quarterback or he
was for the Kentucky Wildcats about 15
years ago and he's probably six feet
he'd probably 6 feet tall five feet wide
someone said he they had to put three
belts on him if he wanted to keep his
pants up otherwise they said sometime he
would have people stand around him and
walk next to him and secretly kind of
hold his pants up on each side because
he was that you know he was a universal
type figure he's the kind of guy you
know he's just so he he he just he was a
universe of his own you wouldn't be
shocked if maybe you were talking to
Jared Lorenzen and he saw a moon over
off the side of him or a satellite
hanging around his neck because he
really was just that robust you know you
wouldn't be surprised if you're you know
you look alright you know you wander
around back of him and they had a Big
Dipper back there you know what I'm not
talking about uh
you know a spare [ __ ] or not like that
I'm talking about you know a
constellation he was just that he was an
orbit of his own and that's Jared
Lorenzen but he gave me this shirt last
time I was in Lexington and a sweet man
and then this time I went and we had a
great time you know it was just you get
there you know you get to Kentucky and
it's you know they got hills and they
got good food man I stayed in a castle
they have a place there called the
Kentucky castle and one of the owners
was a podcast listener is a podcast
listener this gentleman Jacob and his
wife and man they reached out and and
said hey man we love the podcast we'd
love for you to check out the kentucky
castle when you come to town and it was
nice man and i got to meet with them and
we had some food and man this cat they
had they got the best food over there
and this isn't an advertisement for that
castle or anything I mean if the place
you know if I'd had gotten bit by a bat
or something like that I'll let you know
but I didn't do nothing like that and we
had a mean we just had a nice time the
best food I've had in a long time and
the castle you go in there it's like a
damn castle you know you wouldn't be
surprised if you know you are you know
they got somebody outside has the plague
or something or you know I part of me
wanted to stay up all night fighting off
the neighbors with a bow and arrow it's
that kind of joint it's a real deal and
it was nice to stay in the history of
the castle was this a long time ago they
had a man who was in love with a woman
and you know that goes man at being a
being in love with somebody can just I
mean it can reorganize the way your
brain acts you know it can it can
renegotiate the the end of the highways
of thought inside of you you know being
in love with somebody will damn you know
it can it can really create like a
violent relationship between your own
heart and brain you know my heart and my
brain don't really team up that much
unless love is involved I find you know
whether that's love with someone else or
love for something you know most of the
day I find this just me I'm wandering
about the world and you know when I'm
just doing things I'm reacting and I'm
acting and I'm thinking making choices
but then sometimes something will occur
that usually it involves another person
and you get love involved in you and
that's when my brain and my heart have
to team up and then they make choices
together and sometimes sometimes they
make good choices sometimes they make
scared choices but it's usually some
type of love will make those link up and
that's kind of interesting but but yeah
that the castle was was a great spot it
was fun it was a unique experience what
else happened over there you know it was
just good man I got the laid on the way
in i sat next to now kentucky's got some
real you know I mentioned Jared Lorenzen
is a big gentleman he the quarterback
other people who were not quarterbacks
who are just regular humans are also can
be damn ariana grande you know what I'm
saying
this dude i sat on next to the plane on
next to a guy that dude largest dude
ever seen
when he sat in the seat the whole rest
of his body came up around his head so
he was just kind of Punxsutawney filling
inside of himself you know the lady when
she came out with the peanuts she just
set a couple of them up on the ridge
where his head you could just his hair
was just kind of poking out of the top
of them because the seat pushed his body
up so high it just encompassed the whole
sides of his head and neck so you had to
kind of look over the edges of his
shoulders to even see the top of his
head he was down inside of himself and I
checked on him a couple times you know
make sure he was you know living by and
you know when she said a couple peanuts
up on the ridge of him so he could look
you know fire his tongue out and grab
this guy wait no I'm not joking I'm not
making fun of his got weighed 600 pounds
you know I got a couple pictures he
didn't know but I got a couple pictures
with him in case you know something
happens to him he looked like he was
just trapped inside of himself like if
he knew a couple passwords or something
he could get it he could get out of
himself you know it looked like he
wanted somebody to break in there free
him but a large man and he also look
I'll say this he had a sense of humor
about it the lady came down the aisle
the seems not seamstress the flight
attendant and she said you know kind of
get you something to drink he's like
I'll take a beer and and then he goes
can I have it in the can and she goes
you can have it in a cup and then he
goes can I have it in a cone and I think
he was joking but I'm not really sure
but I'll be damned if that dude you know
nine minutes later he ain't [ __ ] you
know he ain't having half of a Guinness
out of a damn waffle cone and that's
when you know you know your weight is
getting ahold of you when you were
drinking beer out of a you know a sugar
cone or waffle cone I mean if you find
yourself putting sprinkles on a Michelob
Ultra
then you probably have maybe dietary
issues but I'm happy to be here today
with you guys and Merry Christmas to you
man let me give you that dude imagine if
your nuts had jingle bells in there can
you imagine that but you roll up on a
couple ladies and knee talking to one of
them she doesn't know if you're
interested in the Flex your nuts a
little and you hear that moist is the
choice after that for the ladies you
know what I'm saying wow man that's if
you had dude girls would know what's up
the girls wouldn't know what's up but
Kentucky was great a lot of people came
out who came out I met a couple had the
same name Joelle they had a man named
Joelle and his and his wife was also
named Joelle and I just said well Joelle
to the world bruh good luck out there
cuz I know I can't believe they found
each other but also kind of Kim believe
they found each other because if you
introduce yourself to somebody your name
is Joelle which isn't you know it's a
nice name but it's not a real name
really that name is Joel you know that's
like somebody if their name is Ronald
and they say my name is Rho in out and
you're like what is your name in their
life it's ro announed
like you mean a [ __ ] Ronald that you
know that's Ronald bro but these people
you know Joelle and I guess after a
while if you introduce yourself to
somebody say hey I'm Joelle they're like
ah you mean Joel and you're like no
Joelle and they're like oh well that's
crazy because there's another crazy
person who doesn't know how letters work
super greatly and they also live you
know over that hillside and then of
course you'd go meet that person but we
had two people with the rare same name
come out who else
a fella named bent came out they had a
family and there they had a mint family
member in a wheelchair and wheelchairs
man a lot of people you see them you
know some people just lazy some people
have a handicaps and I remember when I
first saw a wheelchair I thought I
thought wow this is it you know this is
the future because you could be having
dinner and then be in a living room
you know without having to really move a
muscle and I thought that that was
pretty brilliant but you see these
people in these um in a wheelchair dad a
fella named bent they said his name was
bent and which is ironic because he was
that's he had a you know uh scoliosis
had really got him and he had I mean he
had scoliosis and double scoliosis
I mean it's dude he just had he really
had a just a game a jiangha going on
inside of his of his backbone and he had
you know you couldn't even he was wild
man he was wild and you saw him and you
just he you know he just seemed like he
was doing a lot even though he wasn't
doing much but uh but who else came out
somebody brought me a muffin I remember
that and it was warm
it was warm and I you know if somebody
pull a warm muffin first of all somebody
pull a muffin out of their coat and I've
done some stuff you know you know I'm
saying I'm touched at idiot I couldn't
see what my own eyes
you know I touched the first breasts I
ever touched through a arm electric
fence you know when we were both
children she was only probably maybe 11
or 9 or something I was only you know
maybe 10 so it wasn't really a breasts
yet but it was gonna be at it still
counts so but that was electric fence
and that is you know never have I felt
the Lord and the devil looking at me at
the same time when you reach him for a
breast you know the Lord's little you
know the Lord's a little just milk dud
and at the same time the electricity the
devil is just just whirling all around
your arm but that girl's name was June
was her name named after the month and
got-damn and it didn't take me 30 days
to touch that titty I'll tell you that
did it quickly it did it quickly but
yeah somebody brought me a muffin
there's a warm muffin that's what got me
somebody pull a muffin out of a coat set
it in your hand if it's cold it's not as
and at much of an adventure but that
warm muff that thing hit my hand it was
[ __ ] warm and I mean really warm I'm
not talking body heat like if you give
me a muff and you've had it in your coat
and that bitch's just body you know that
[ __ ] is 98.6 Brian I'm just thinking
damn it's just a kind of a you know this
is a muffin has just been body heated up
that's kind of gross for me some people
you know some families you'll see they
got a you know a chubby uncle with a
fever and he gots his shirt off and they
keep him muffins warm on his back
because somebody to have a fever dough
probably don't keep a muffin it probably
101 102
and dammit is under if you ever had a
fever warmed muffin but God dang melts
right off the damn boom brother so but
yeah this muffin this man must had a
fever or something going on maybe an
infection because this thing was coming
in warmer than regular body temperature
and I appreciated that somebody pulled
on a warm muffin and handed me that
somebody gave me a snicker a lot of
people came for pictures with the strap
there maybe the last tour of the strap
you know we'll see
might not be we'll see but uh but it was
great man it was a lot of fun and a lot
of fun in the club you know they you
know the staff and everybody really
brought in a lot of joy re manis came
the feature we did a get the cash we hit
some cash in the castle hotel room and
helped a young cleaning lady you know
make some extra money we'll put that up
soon and we just did some some neat
stuff and I want to thank our patreon
errs and just thank you guys you know
it's been a long year it had been a long
year man I was thinking about actually
maybe toning down some of the guest
episodes and just doing more I don't
know you know I like doing them I just
want to
times when I do the guest episodes I
feel like like I have to be I don't know
I guess if I feel like I have to pretend
to be like a smart person or something
you know or I just have to pretend that
not pretend but I don't know I just have
to you know I have to be so present and
sometimes I don't like being super
present you know and I think some of
that even probably more I think about it
like you know some of it probably goes
back to just you know being young and I
didn't enjoy the world as much and so if
I was present it was more painful
whereas if I could be more in my you
know just sit inside of the safety of my
own brain or something like that or
inside of myself then it felt more
comfortable but but we'll see man I'm
just figuring it out because because I
like being able to just be more
comfortable in these episodes and not
feel like and sometimes with the guests
I just I don't know but we might
experiment with some stuff you know I
want to be brave enough to make changes
as I go even when things are going good
you know because I want to be able to
take care of myself and feel healthy and
it's been a lot as men it's been a wild
year it's been a busy busy year but what
else man we got oh I'll tell you some
new tour dates we got coming up I'll
tell you also we have a sale going on on
the website it's 10% off everything at
theof on comm and we have a new Rat King
shirt that I'll go up later this week
but we have shows coming up the omaha
funnybone january 11th and 12th omaha
nebraska january 18th 19th and 20th our
vine improv Addison Texas January 25th
and 26th
and I was just there on Thursday I
stopped in Dallas and did one night
there and thank you to everybody that
came out just some viewed a lot of
beautiful Souls people drove in from
different places and you know I met a
young lady was Nicaraguan she came out
who else we had a young lady that made
me some artwork tour artwork Lindsay I
think was her name she came out and
reminded me that I forgot to pay her or
she didn't remind me but I was second I
saw her I was like up so got settled up
with her so I'm grateful that I got to
see her you know when just good people
people came out a lot of joy that show
was a little stressful you know just
because that you travel you get right
there and you go up and you know just
been feeling a little rattled but that's
okay
operation feeling good is what's gonna
go on now Addison improv I'll be back
there though January 25th 26 Columbus
Ohio February 8th and 9th Houston improv
February 22nd and 23rd and then I'll be
at the Wilbur in Boston and the Borgata
Hotel and Casino those are March 8th and
March 9th as well I'm not ready to
announce it yet but we got a couple of
other continents that we might be
hitting so a lot of exciting stuff and
I'm grateful man you know it's you know
I get to live out my dreams I mean
that's crazy to think that isn't it
that's crazy to think that I get to live
some of my dreams out and you know I
think about long-term stuff and and you
know somehow through this podcast we're
gonna help other people live out some of
their dreams as well I don't know how
we're gonna do it but some of it I'm
just gonna let it happen organically
instead of trying to push and you know
for me it's hard to let go and just let
the world kind of occur sometimes
because I'm afraid if I do that that it
won't take care of me sometimes
you know part of me just doesn't trust
the world in certain ways I think but
anyhow that is uh that's what's going on
those are those dates we got us some
calls that came in do speak in a
Kentucky Kentucky teacher arrested for
sending nude pictures to former student
a middle school teacher in West Virginia
Ramsey was her name
I mean come on dude if I had a hot
teacher named Ramsey Ramsey look there's
some names you know that's like if you
had a teacher named you know miss uh
miss [ __ ] ttan dude there's no way
and if she's hot
yeah there's no way I ain't gonna you
know all the artwork we do in class I'm
gonna have secret hidden pictures in my
dick and the artwork they're gonna call
me Walt Dixon II you feel me I'm hiding
dicks and everything it could even just
be a picture of like an orange we're
drawing the first picture ever in Miss
[ __ ] Tain's art class and I'm you
know I'm hiding a little gang behind the
orange be like damn that orange has a
big thick stem on it like on either then
I miss finding time but some names it's
um you can't have certain names and not
expect certain thing to happen to you
you know if your name is uh you know
Donnie cement and people throwing
[ __ ] quikrete and sacks are quick
creating your house and [ __ ] while
you're trying to sleep well that's what
you get if your name is uh you know
Larry Raven
oh that's Larry Raven up there he work
at the Ramada or he used to you know for
he got shot but if your name is Larry
Raven and people always you know hot and
crows and and dark birds in your car and
I'm not talking about black girls I'm
talking about dark birds okay
if people always hiding dark birds in
your car you can't be upset if your name
is uh you know Cynthia yogurt and people
you know dripping a little bit of Dan
and on your back and stuff at the
ballgame who you gonna be mad at Cynthia
the person behind you with a couple
pints of 2% or your parents for having a
baby knowing the last name gonna be
yogurt I think it's the latter but what
do I know
you know what do I know and I think
maybe that's one thing I realized about
doing the interview is I don't enjoy
sometimes is I feel like I have to know
stuff you know and maybe that's just a
pressure I put on myself you know but
you know this is all a learning
experience and what I'm learning as I'm
going and I'm just so grateful to to be
here today with you guys but yet the
teacher in Kentucky Ramsey former Miss
Kentucky pageant winner sent the photos
to former student she's had been
suspended and I'm wondering why this
stuff is happening like like I get a
male teacher being attracted to female
students some of that is something
there's a nature in there you know
there's a lot of predators you know
Chris Hansen is on this week episode and
a lot of predators and predator is just
somebody that sees something and wants
it and the part of him that says no you
probably shouldn't have it they tell
that part to go [ __ ] and they keep going
a lot of predators are men you know
because that's in our nature if you
watch the nature Channel it's usually
you know man animals is killing others
they don't really have snapped the
animals episode season you know even
though they should I
to see snap just like a couple female
pandas with a little [ __ ] you know
with a little 22 or something you know
our female pan are just pulling out a
damn little six-shooter and popping off
over there at the zoo gunning down a
couple of meerkats or something what
else what else the holidays I'm gonna go
home to Louisiana I'm excited about that
I'll be there in New Orleans that shows
been sold out that middle school teacher
why does that happen now more when I was
in Middle School
you know we had I remember we have one
teacher I think I mean I was look dude I
was the little dude who would truck all
the teachers I thought was hot my
buddies would always be like aw do you
see you know miss guy our faller you
know they had a rumor going around when
I was young they said one of the
teachers had three breasts so you know
we was really up in arms about that
and when I say up in arms it means we
have both of our arms up like this and
then loui was sprung in the middle
that's all that's three arms because
your dick is just an arm that has you
know semen deep in the back of it and
and we would you know when you hear that
a teacher have three breasts you're
excited about it you're fired up now I'm
saying next thing you know I'm Nicolas
Cage and ah you know what time to kill
or whatever art history or something
where they're finding the treasure and
so you're curious but I was at you know
I was so I was so desperate for that
female affection why be up there they
have a 75 year old teacher you know miss
Rapp or I think we had to let him miss
Rapp or miss one lady I think miss fart
was her name you know PHA Artie and she
wanted us to you know respect the name
and I'm like oh we are 12 years old
ah so but I thought she was fine as [ __ ]
my buddies would be like do what are you
doing I'm like I'm not here you know
I'd be writing love letters in the dirt
in the schoolyard and she walk up you
know miss fart would just kind of blow
on up and it threw the breeze and just
you know what's going on here and I'd
like to rub it all off my foot and just
you know erase all the message my foot
oh nothing oh nothing miss fart just you
know just looking for treasure you know
or something you know just writing a
message for help in case the plane goes
by you know just practice and in case
I'm ever like in a avalanche or
something you know I'll do stuff like
that but I loved any of the teachers man
busted looking all of them all of them I
loved all of a man I just had that
affection but we didn't have that hot
teacher what do you think it is out
there in the universe today that's
making these hot teachers you send the
pictures to the children like that's a
that's a that's a question I have and
I'd love for you guys to hit the hotline
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three and let me you know what is
it is it that these women you know they
still want to be young you know because
this used to be a male thing that was
happening we had a teacher he got pumped
you know everybody did remember about 20
years ago every tea every school had a
dude they got pop the janitor every
assistant coach if you were assistant
coach dude you was touching somebody's
ass and you got busted you know they
didn't these dudes was all perverts we
had a whole fight you know they had you
know everybody had these perverts
running us shows back then but I wonder
if now that women are becoming more like
men in some places or feeling pressured
more to behave like men if they're doing
that if they're like engaging with the
young boys if it's a power thing or the
boys feeling more motivated and they're
starting this
and the women are just unable to reject
somebody shy of young advances because
some of these young dudes that you know
14 years old they got a little bit of
slicker in their hair and they got a
little bit of you know they put in a
cologne and her hair in the back and
they doing you know they'll have a buddy
they might not smoke but they might have
a friend you know blow a little bit of
mile brow smoke on them and that smoke
if you go by a lady and they smell that
smoke on a child they think oh he's been
in a fire or he's kind of sexy because
dude you put a little bit of mom Brown
smoke on a 14 15 year-old boy kind of I
mean that's gonna really that temptation
factor goes up but uh but what do you
think it is what do you guys think is
going on in the world that this kind of
stuff is happening now I know the news
is just reporting it more and I know the
news especially if it's a white kind of
thing going on if it's a white teach or
white student then they're definitely
reporting that because I strongly
believe that the media has some severe
issues he's just wants to make white
people look the worst even though most
of the media is owned by white people so
it's a really tricky deal going on and I
could be wrong about that you know I
could be wrong about that but sometimes
I do feel that way but what do you
think's going on why is that happening
why is that happening because I'm
sitting in clients and a hot teacher
look man if I'm a kid the first thing I
want to do is hook up with her
I'm also then probably going to be
scared you know I might be scared cuz
you might think well what if she gets
pregnant what's going on she has a
family and y'all so you're gonna tell
your friends if you're 15 years old and
you got pictures of the teachers taught
taunts you showing those to the friends
that's gonna happen first thing ain't
trading baseball cards you know what I'm
saying I got a picture I miss farts
tant's Brown I got a picture of Miss
farts tarts you feel me but I wonder
what it is man if you have some thoughts
hit the hotline on why that's happening
so much now is there something going on
in the world is it just a you know
free-for-all nine eight five six six
four nine five zero three one other news
thing that happened on Nick Cannon came
to the aid of Kevin Hart Kevin Hart got
reprimanded he got asked to emcee the
one of these awards shows that you know
it's um they give awards to you know
it's companies that give awards to
actors that they own basically a lot of
times so you'll see you know it's like
oh the Academy but it's all tied in
together and it's all owned by the same
companies or supported by the same
company so it's all a bunch of [ __ ]
a lot of times it's a lot of rich people
award another rich people I find but
also could be angry because they've
never given me meena me nothing but the
now Kevin Hart what he did was he got
asked to host this awards Oscars and
then they went through his tweets and
said well he said homophobic stuff in
the past and now he needs to apologize
for it and he told him to [ __ ] off
basically he did but then he did
apologize but also told him to [ __ ] off
they didn't want to do it and I commend
him you know I commend him for that
I don't think if five or six people on
Twitter get angry about something then
that's to justify everyone and the more
that that kind of stuff keeps happening
and that the media really caters to
those small voices just to create
controversy the more you're making the
masses angry I think because their
voices aren't heard not only not heard
but not respected and so Nick Cannon
came to his aid and made fun of other
you know retweeted old things that other
people had tweeted in the past you know
you know called out Amy Schumer Sarah
Silverman and Chelsea Handler you know
three Jewish comedians
that were I guess I've been allowed to
host shows even though that they called
people [ __ ] in past tweets and good for
him man good for somebody be able to say
something you know I think you need a
black guy to say something I think if a
white guy bring this brings this up they
wouldn't even let this be an article so
I'm happy that you know that people are
standing up for their friends in the
industry and that finally people are
saying oh well it's interesting that
these three white women can behave a
certain way but but this man it doesn't
have some of the same freedoms so good
for Kevin you know good for Kevin man
you know it's not fair that you know you
have a lot of these you know and but all
three of these women condescending you
know you know these are all women who
you know to me make fun of the rest of
America and look down upon those people
who are less fortunate than them and
believe they can tell people how to vote
and how to behave just because they have
money a lot of extreme white privilege
with these women you know so good for
them good for those guys standing up
against against basically what's not you
know you want equality you got to treat
people equal and [ __ ] these boring-ass
Oscar who gives a [ __ ]
half the movies they pick always suck
dick anyway done Kirk's the only good
movie I've seen in the past five years
but anyhow that's just my thoughts and I
could be totally now it could be totally
wrong but let's get into some calls man
first also want to tell you if you own a
business or if you are thinking about
starting one this course is a hundred
percent absolutely for you it's the
smart set-up guide business building 101
and the gentleman who there's a
gentleman named Martin O'Neill who helps
me out with a lot of our stuff here at
this past weekend and he has now a
course it's easy to understand it's easy
to implement online video course that
breaks down
need-to-know information that will save
you massive amounts of time money and
energy building your business and I
cannot support this guy enough this the
way he has it set up it's acute its
effective if you want to take a business
you currently have and get it to the
next level online and have it become
profitable this is how you do it or if
you have a family member they're
starting a small business this course
will be great for them in just two and a
half hours you will develop a pro level
understanding of how logo design and
brand identity can make or break your
business the best way to build your
website and online store how to outrank
your competition on Google social media
marketing how to secure new clients and
maintain them long term the course is
created by Marty O'Neil owner of drastic
graphics who has over a decade's worth
of experience working with some of the
biggest brands and performers in the
world for the month of December you can
get a 30 percent discount visit smart
setup guide calm and use coupon code
Theo at checkout that is smart
setup guide calm and use coupon code the
o th e o at checkout and the smart
set-up guide business building 101 it's
effective I'm not this is a real thing
it's definitely effective and Martin
cares he cares about helping young
people he straight outta Buffalo
hard-working dude seven hundred percent
Irish he cares about helping young
people achieve their next step and and
this is a way to do it so check that out
as well
skills share is an online learning
platform with over 20,000 classes in
business design technology and more you
can take classes in social media
marketing data science mobile
photography creative writing you name it
some of the classes that this past
weekend listeners have signed up for
include how to make Android apps with no
programming experience
say hello to After Effects and trap
music production
whether you're trying to deepen your
professional skill set start a side
hustle or just export a new passion
skill share is there to keep you
learning and thriving get two months of
skill share for just 99 cents
that's right skill share is offering
this past weekend listeners two months
of unlimited access to over 20,000
classes for just 99 cents to sign up go
to Skillshare comm slash Theo again go
to Skillshare dot-com slash Theo to
start your two months now that skill
shared comm slash Theo and skill share
has been a great supporter and man if
you want specific things you want to go
there I want to learn this and I'm going
to learn that because I need that
education because when I look inside of
myself I'm missing elements you know I'm
juggling balls but I don't have no balls
well you can go get your balls you can
go get your ideas you can go get your
facts and your specific information at
Skillshare dot-com slash Theo
alright we had a lot of calls that came
in to this past weekend this past
episode and I want to get to some of
those right now
thank you guys as always the hotline is
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three I would love to know your
thoughts on you know what do you think
that is that you know female teachers
that were seeing more of that these days
[Music]
and why what is that is that you know
there's something bigger going on like
at a macro level that we you know or is
it just a little bit of straight Pervin
and now we have technology and you know
and the times are changing let me know
what you think here's a couple calls
that came in here we go thank you very
much for calling my name is Luke thank
you for calling Luke homeward just
listening to your podcast on your story
man when the call-in tell you I'm
alcoholic been on the sober train for
about two years now
oh well well thanks man thanks for
calling and congratulations on on two
years on the sober train all aboard
you know this the Polar Express is
coldest [ __ ] on this bit sometimes but a
lot of times it's very warm
homeward little advice or a little good
advice I got from my sponsor early on
started going to the gym about the same
time I started going to AAA I got some
complaints talking about telling him man
I like come to your meetings I don't
feel like these people in here doing it
the right way
Yatta Yatta Yatta and he told me he said
man it is just like the gym everybody in
there and doing it the right way well
you might not be doing the right way but
I came to figure out it was a good place
for me to go I wound up being better
when I went and that's all that mattered
man so anyway two years sober about 60
pounds down in two years so that's good
you know for the mattress Olympics a
little bit better at that there you go
boy whoo cool hand luke warm dick Luke
you know what I'm saying
thanks for making me laugh right there a
little more onward anyway one question I
heard Rogan one time talking about how
the best comics that's ever lived a
pretty scarred on the inside if you
could go back and change and just have a
normal life but that meant it would suck
up your the ability to be a great
comedian would you make that exchange I
would hope you wouldn't but I didn't
live through all that so I just wanted
how you felt about that so anyway Gang
Gang you beautiful Koo Yong gang gang
brother merry Christmas to you and I
appreciate the warm sentiment you know
and congratulations man you're right you
know it's like you you keep going to
this program and no matter what I just
keep going you know last sign I didn't
want to go when I got home I didn't want
to do anything but I rolled over and
checked out a meeting down the street
[Music]
you know what I trade you know you know
I think for a long time I probably would
have you know I think now you know it's
so funny the other night I'm telling a
story on stage about my brother and I
being kids and my brother and I do not
have a lot of fond memories from being
children together we don't have memories
of you know playing together or enjoying
each other's company that much and and
it's sad kind of you know it's a little
sad it's okay
it's said I'm not getting into it don't
you know it you know an emo hole here
but but one thing I'm noticing now when
I'm telling stories on the stage it's
like I get to recreate it's like I get
to make something fun out of something
that wasn't fun a long time ago so it's
almost like I get to reshape it now and
it's kind of cool for me because I know
when my brother sees some of these
materials and sees me do some of these
new stories you know inside of him it's
gonna start to fill in a place in him
where he you know maybe there he feels
you know sadness or regret because we
didn't have some of we didn't have a
warm time you know we didn't have a
connection so I feel grateful you know
that there's something inside of me that
makes me able to fashion a story or
something in enough of a fun way that it
can be like a cement or like a you know
a caulk see a ulk in caulk some people
you say caulk and they have you know a
couple ladies open or mouths up and even
one dude over there you know is working
at the smoothie shop but I'm saying
caulk something for carpenters but you
know it's all that these stories now can
almost it's like it goes back in and
fills it in a little bit it's like I can
kind of not recreate it but just make it
in a way where it's a little more fun
but you know I know that a lot of my
family is struggled if if going back in
time meant that it would make things
easier
for some of them then yeah I would give
up you know I would give up the you know
the the the fun that I have sometimes
with some of the success that's happened
especially this year you know because it
makes me because that because then it's
not just it's not just me it's other
people you know if I could just to me
would help them then I it would be hard
for me to probably say no but you know I
appreciate you calling man I appreciate
you thinking about it and uh you know I
just hope that um you know staying sober
has kept me in a place where I'm able to
you know create better and and that in
its own way is has been helping me
reshape and make a joy out of the past
so but I'm grateful for your call Amanda
congratulations again man and good luck
at the mattress Olympics dude you know
I'm saying that Decathlon is a real
sport
you know family name alright let's take
another call here we go
mr. Rat King my name is Paulo I've been
clean off that that sweet heroin for for
18 years
and uh I really enjoy listening to your
podcast Wow thank you for calling Paul
18 years man that's incredible dude
Jesus that's how human that's a young
adult
that's 18 years you've been clean you've
been clean off of heroin for a young
adult
so you find any 18 year old you know
Marcus or you know Jan we had a black
kid in our town Janet his name janitor
Johnson how in the [ __ ] you're gonna
have a kid name of janitor you know but
you know they call him JJ but that's
janitor Johnson you got to give you know
at least call him something you know
airline pilot Johnson or give the dude a
little bit of chance um but anyway yeah
so you're you're older than you know you
you got the sobriety of a you know you
got a whole an adult you have a sober
adult living
you an 18 year old anyway homeward enjoy
listening to you talk about your your
ordeals with cocaine and all that but I
do got to say it you got to look into
that that tradition 11 where it talks
about keeping anonymity at the level
press radio and films I know you got to
find some way to talk about your
recovery adventures without specifically
naming AAA or meetings or something
I was listening you you mentioned that
you know you you like to break the rules
and stuff but the thing is though this
isn't like it's not like you're at
school and the teacher is telling you
not to do something and you're being
cool and rebellious by breaking the
rules the problem is that this is your
program and your fellowship and those
traditions are there so that the
fellowship survives thank you for
calling man and I appreciate you know
you bring in this point up and he's
saying there's a tradition that says
you're supposed to there's a tradition
that says that not you're supposed to
but the tradition says you're supposed
to protect the anonymity of of the
program at press radio and film so that
is what he is referencing and what is he
he's referencing that I am struggling to
do here onward because the the problem
with it is if all these people listen to
you they get inspired and they they come
to associate you with what recovery is
and they need recovery let's say and
then it doesn't work out for you you
relapse or whatever then they decide
well recovery doesn't work because it
didn't work for a CEO yeah that's a
really good point man you know and it's
funny you say this because I was just
thinking about this the other day I was
just thinking about after I was telling
that story this week I was like may you
know maybe I shouldn't it's I shouldn't
have told it I was feeling you know just
because yeah for that same reason if
people you know if I don't stay in this
program then people look at the program
and say it doesn't work so yeah I
appreciate you bringing that up man it
is a good point man in
[Music]
you know and it has been hard I think my
motivation to talk about it was because
I've talked about being sober but I I
don't you know I guess I'm one of my
listeners to know or I wanted you know
the group here to know more why you know
why why I do that you know why I feel
like I need to or why the program or
getting into the sobriety help for me
but I should you are you're right man
you know I should have done it and not
mention the program's name and I think
that that's something that I can do a
better job of you know I feel a little
bit selfish I guess even though I don't
feel like my motivations came from a
selfish place but I do appreciate you
bringing that up
onward and so you put people at danger
you know you put people in danger is the
problem sounds like maybe you're just
going to meetings but not doing steps
with a sponsor I'm not sure but you
didn't you mentioned what you talked a
lot about meetings but you didn't
mention anything about steps so but if
that's the case you know you're well I
don't want to tell you what to do but
you're not really exactly I mean you're
not really doing the program if you're
not doing the steps so maybe look into
that well that's a good point you know
the program you know step work is the
program so yeah if I'm not doing the
steps I'm not really doing I'm not doing
the steps you know and that's true I
mean I've gotten through you know I've
gotten up some of the steps a few times
man but you know I've never haven't
gotten to the stoop you know but I hope
to and you know I work with different
sponsors and recently you know started
working with a new guy so we'll see but
I think that you're right in the sense
that I could find other ways to talk
about it and I appreciate you bringing
that point up because you know that
program is a million times bigger than
than any one of us and
and I probably could find better ways to
be more respectful of that you know but
thank you for bringing that up
but if you were if you were in a program
and you haven't gotten through the steps
you know that doesn't mean that you
can't still keep going back to the
program and you can still be sober and
not I've gotten through your step work
and I'm not saying that for myself I'm
just saying that in case there's anybody
out there that needs to hear it I'm a
slow learner you know and something
about me doesn't want to sometimes you
know I don't want to do stuff sometimes
I don't want to do what other people
want me to do you know but hopefully
some of that you know I'll just learnt
continuing to learn as I as I as I go
you know but thanks for calling brother
onward let's take another call hey Eddie
Eddie from Lancaster Lancaster
Pennsylvania is where's that outside of
[ __ ] I don't know I think that's Amish
country and they got a show now breaking
Amish and Hollywood's trying to [ __ ]
break up the Amish bruh get a [ __ ]
life the Oscars bro who gives a [ __ ]
dude I'd rather watch UFC [ __ ] reruns
homeward ah PA not California [ __ ] that
but anyway I heard dude Gregg called and
left last show just one say
congratulations on your sobriety that's
tremendous that's [ __ ] awesome and
then CEO you were seeing people you said
a couple times people telling you they
shouldn't talk about sobriety and a
public forum or whatever and [ __ ] that
dude every other show is basically every
other podcast is basically celebrities
talking about all the [ __ ] they drank
how qualities to smoke weed and do you
know like there's not a lot of light
entertainment or support out there for
God is trying to try to get off on the
wagon off away on the wagon so I think
you should keep it updated I think you
are a fantastic voice for a lot of young
men especially because you got that you
know you got that charisma you're like
power fun [ __ ] and I think a lot of
tough guys out here need sort of
permission to be honest with themselves
about you know everything all the kind
of stuff you talked about so keep it up
man I love the show and I think
gratulations man that's tremendous and
better please get that hitter dude
well thanks for calling you know I think
that as you're talking man I'm thinking
uh you know I'm thinking that I think
the main goal in talking about the
sobriety and being sober was because I
wanted people to know how I felt you
know what made me get into being you
know being sober was how I felt man it
wasn't about drugs and alcohol but it
was how I felt and at some point I found
myself using some drugs too because I
didn't have any way to feel
I wasn't feeling anything anymore that
was good and so those when I would use
drugs it made me feel something and uh
and so my main goal was really to
iterate more how I was feeling and maybe
I shouldn't have focused on the program
that much this isn't it I don't want
this to become a show about sobriety
about that kind of stuff you know like
there's a lot of different facets and
worlds to my life you know but I think I
think you know you your call and the
previous caller it's like I I do want to
share and I also could have probably
been more respectful of the program as I
did it but you know I think I Indiana
I just wanted if there's other dudes you
know young men out there even women or
lesbians bro they got you know how many
lesbians hit me up on the on the on the
low trying to get these haircut tips man
a fantastical you know um just a real
fan of fantastical amount but I don't
want there to be young men out there who
are feeling certain ways and don't know
what's going on you know I don't want
those I don't want those people to feel
alone and if I can not help man I'm not
trying to be any kind of damn Sherpa but
I'm just trying to share some of what's
going on with me because or what was
going on with me and what is sometimes
because
because sometimes I hear people share
and it helps me see what's going on with
myself so but thank you thank you for
your call man and I'm gonna try to do it
when I can and in ways that are in ways
that are probably more respectful and
also I probably needed to hear that
young man the previous caller tell me to
get you know get into my step work man
so homework Oh word take another call
here we go nine eight five six six four
nine five zero three yeah hey Shannon
Schubert and Schubert sound like an
ice-cream you know it boy mm-hmm dang
get a couple scoops of Shannon you know
what I'm saying
homework because I was so sad because
your New Orleans show was sold out well
Never Say Never
or don't take no for an answer is my
message because that's what I'm so
excited I'm contact at the House of
Blues and I did this for you just so I
could go see you me and my son
I bought a membership to the house of
liquors don't know if I ever go back but
you never know anyway a lot of
membership and I've got to come see you
oh I'm sorry Titus I cannot wait so I
hope after the show that we get to meet
you and take a picture with you anyway I
just want to call in like him look
forward to seeing you in New Orleans
Thank You Shannon
I appreciate that I'm excited that you
are that's a great call
I appreciate that made me feel good you
know what made me feel good because
towards the end I could tell how excited
you were and a man that made me feel
good you know I'm glad that that you
guys are coming and it's gonna be fun
man you know we got it it's gonna be fun
my family's coming not my mother but my
brothers coming out my sister her
husband
my boy Dustin Poirier is supposed to
become and dude that's the neck one of
the next UFC champs who else do my some
of the guys from Bishop Gunn are coming
down we're gonna do a little after-party
right there in the foundation room right
next door my buddy DJ sach field one of
my best friends from growing up he's a
newscaster turned DJ you know that's the
dark arts emo in and he's gonna be there
and yeah I want people to come do your
drinking afterwards you know you can
have a you know have a drink before but
just don't get you know let's don't make
it too rowdy during the show I want
people to enjoy the experience and then
we'll have fun afterwards and um but I'm
grateful that you're coming you know
what's funny you remind me sorry I said
I get so amped up
you remind me they had a I I joined an
Alumni Association one time when I was
at UCLA and when I was eight and I
wasn't there as a student I went to the
gym but to get a gym membership you had
to join the Alumni Association an Alumni
Association that sounds like some kind
of Klu Klux Klan's [ __ ] but it's not
it's some it's just like a group of old
people would I really like to drink
outside of the stadium but anyhow I had
to join that and when I joined it
I got a membership to the gym at UCLA so
I could use the gym down the street the
thing was this if I had to do one event
for them so I chose this special Olympic
type of deal so I'm there helping out
one day the wooden Center on UCLA campus
and they got and this you know I was
dabbling a little bit in the dark arts
at the time you know you might if you
tickled me hard enough in the front of
my nose a little bit of coke might fall
out of it and they had a dude in the
bathroom he's going in there I've been
talking to him at the event found out we
both like the party next thing you know
we're in the bathroom you know it's
probably 4:30 and afternoon
doing a little bit of um you know of
coke you know cocaine and and that's
crazy man when you're doing you know
you're in one of the big handicap stalls
with an actual handicapped person this
dude was in a wheelchair you know he was
in a wheelchair and and wearing there
doing coke and [ __ ] and I started to
feel a little bit bad you know because
he's in a wheelchair and I'm not and uh
anyway other people in the bathroom and
the [ __ ] got a little bit weird and so
he went out he went out of the stall
and I didn't know what to do you know
I'm still in the stall and people in the
bathroom know I'm in there and they're
like well what in the [ __ ] is going on
you know and I didn't know what to do so
I end up just she's sitting down on the
ground in like when I got it when I open
the stall door and kind of drug myself
on the ground out of the stall and out
the door of the hallway and I guess I
mean I was just [ __ ] up at that point
you know when I've done this kind of
[ __ ] before I got stuck in enough in the
house with a lady who didn't have any
you know she only had two appendages or
arms she didn't have all four appendages
and I got stuck in a house with that
lady and uh and I guess I just felt
nervous I kind of drug myself out on the
floor because I didn't want to I guess I
felt like I was showing off I guess with
my legs but anyway but anyway I joined
an Alumni Association one time to get a
gym membership is what I'm trying to
tell you so thank you so much let's take
another call all morden idea this is a
conscious show in DC last Saturday the
Late Show great [ __ ] show just want
to say thanks for coming to DC thanks
for coming out to the show Zack yeah
that was fun over there in DC man it was
awhile we did it fast and we did it
right
yeah I live in rural Virginia outside of
Charlottesville so it's a little bit of
a drive not huge fan of the district but
come to see though and I just want to
say it was awesome how you stuck around
met people took pitches and [ __ ] I
thought that was really pretty awesome
i money remember me like I did tell you
that I was a P I listen to your podcast
all the time cuz I'm in a car doing
surveillance driving all over Virginia
oh yeah you're a P I I remember you dude
and I remember being young they had you
know we had a dude I mean a peon first
of all when you hear it I remember being
young you hear private investigator you
think oh it's an animal you think oh
it's a John ecologist you know those are
the first two thing I think but then we
had a dude in the woods this guy
detective Mike and he everybody said
that he was private investigator well
turned out he's just [ __ ] homeless
bro he's peeping tom and this buddies
have a lot more peeping toms you'd see
them you know comparing notes and
[ __ ] you know sharing ladders and all
of that kind of stuff sometime you know
down behind a MP super store down there
off Jackson Avenue but this was you know
what time when when it was more popular
when people weren't doing as much social
media so peeping tom was a good way to
you know see who's hot in the area it
was kind of like tender but you had to
have a ladder and this man was in the
woods all the time we're like oh dude
he's like yeah I'm detective I'm doing
surveillance well for [ __ ] months we
think he's doing surveillance and [ __ ]
and turns out he's just [ __ ] homeless
dude living in the woods man this dude
Detective Mike and I guess I guess I can
quit calling them all detective because
he wasn't you know he was shooting dope
alright let's take another call
onward he a first-time caller
becoming a big fan over the past year I
bought the podcast I finished the
donnell rawlings episode
oh yeah Donnell Rawlings and done ill
man the funniest guy that I've ever seen
or just talked to or even to did done L
is so funny he's so funny homeward and
it was really refreshing
the way that the conversation involving
culture and race frame you didn't really
tiptoe around anything he dropped some
old knowledge especially about ignorant
breeding racism the difference between
the two and I just want to say you
expressed thoughts and feelings I've had
I was the only white kid in my my grade
six or seventh grade I went through that
phase and you know there's a difference
between being aware and being
discriminatory and the fact that you're
willing to admit that you have these
questions whereas other people might
just bury it for fear of seeming like
something they're not just meant a lot
to me and just once they love the show
motivate me help keep my spirits high
and maybe one day I get to get a lick
out old cinnamon Mike's palm if I'm just
looking up dude and I'll say this man
and that man was a friend of my dad's
and he passed but I want to say that
cinnamon was he did it he made it at the
house and that man he'd put a little
cinnamon on his palm and he had to palm
warmest palm to I mean he'd probably
running a fever a little bit but when
you licked that seminoff it was like
having just a damn warm bowing out the
oven but thank you for the call man in
Donnell Rollins you know people say
sometimes we don't have enough diverse
episode I've reached out to some of my
favorite black artists and a lot of them
do not want to come on or have just said
oh I'm coming and never [ __ ] call
back you know so you know we definitely
made an effort and I think we do have
some diversity on here I think we've
done pretty good and I don't like a lot
of too much force diversity unless we're
talking Mexican people in the NBA
how you gonna have half your fan base
and is Mexican and you know I have any
view got [ __ ] zero Mexicans in the
NBA you tell them you don't want to
watch a 5-2 dude named Papa shoot it
from half-court every day wearing a pair
of [ __ ] Dockers bro come on come
um but I think there's a lot of race
stuff that's not talked about I know I
chime in about it a lot here and there
it was nice to have done L come on
because then you can talk about it with
somebody you know I loved hearing him
say that you know no more excuses you
know because everybody needs to hear
that message you know there's a lot of
uh you know there's a lot of like excuse
stuff in America there's a lot of
excuses bestially the media but the
media doesn't help man the mainstream
the news [ __ ] them bruh they don't want
the bad I don't care what network you're
watching fie seeing they don't want that
they want they're selling you what they
think you want to see every time you got
to remember some of that so I think it
you know I'm fortunate to have
conversations with people that's legit
you know that's different than me but
who were also you know smart and willing
to discuss stuff and I thought there
were times where I wish I was have been
a little bit braver to share some of my
real thoughts and fears you know it's
you know I don't get to say a lot of
times like I get scared a lot a lot of
black people scare me you know this if
they because I had bad experiences
growing up getting beat up and
threatened by black people constantly
and I don't get to say that you know
it's like if you say that it's instead
of and I don't say it from a place where
like I want something bad to happen to
them but I do say it from a place where
it's like I know that other people feel
this way I've had a similar experience
and why is that never discussed you know
the mainstream a lot of times just wants
to make white people look bad especially
poor white people and I don't think
they're doing a service to anybody by
doing that and I think that black people
definitely need more opportunity you
know in America they need to be granted
more opportunity you have to get you
know you have to give them opportunity
for them to experience opportunity but
at the same time I think a lot of black
people rest on not wanting to there's a
lot of excuse culture that's that's been
embedded in the black culture over time
you know and in a lot of culture I think
we all need to point fingers at
ourselves and so those I guess are some
of my thoughts but beige power man I
think the futures beige and
that's where we're gonna end up so we
need to try and get there as happily as
we can and I love being able to talk
with people like Donnell because you
know he knows and I know both of us we
know that each other have good hearts
and that and that we're imperfect and
that uh and that we can be wrong about
stuff you know we can be wrong about
stuff you know I wish that in a way we
could all learn to be wrong about stuff
together I think that that would help
all of us and also what the [ __ ] do I
know man
what the [ __ ] do I know you know these
are just it's just my perspective of the
world there's there's billions of
perspectives
you know there's 350 million
perspectives of America in America alone
so own word path Carolina but thanks for
calling brother I appreciate your call
and I appreciate your sentiment and I
appreciate you listening and um you know
I'm never gonna get anything right in
this podcast this conversation there's
nothing to get right you know I'm just
trying to be alive and and be okay
homework I see your Monday podcast with
you talking about your parents and not
feeling loved and just want to get some
insight so there's this concept called
attachment theory and it's all about how
we trust and bond with others the way
you learned to bond with others as a
child will influence how I would bond
with others as an adult and young kids
who learn to trust caretakers from they
business form a secure attachment and if
they don't they formed this thing called
an insecure attachment wow that's
interesting I just looked it up
attachment theory states that a strong
emotional and physical attachment to at
least one primary caregiver is critical
to personal development John Bowlby I'm
guessing named after the bowels
first coined the term as a result of his
studies involving the development
psychology of children from various
backgrounds that's interesting
a strong emotional and physical
attachment to at least one primary
caregiver is critical to personal
development I mean I could believe that
let's hear more from you thank you so
much for calling brother I suggest
googling and checking it out
well basically insecure attachment can
lead us to do some wild things in a
relationship have trust issues be clingy
you know whatever damn brothers I did I
remember one time you know when I was
young I was in love with a girl and man
she looked like a damn exotic war you
know just a damn she looked like
remember that show fire and ice or
whatever no what was it called American
ninja warriors the original one no
American Gladiators and they had men and
women on there and they all look like
lesbians that were really on steroids
are on Decca 30 or whatever or d-ball
9000 you know that motherfucker's that
you know they'd be on there crying and
just having tests 200 just dripping out
of their eye sockets they were on all
types of uppers and you know steroids
and that show American Gladiators all
the boys and girls all look the same
they did so much steroids that they just
had blonde hair and then I think and
their tits turned into muscles and they
all move to Florida but I dated a girl
in high school in college that was just
stunning and she looked real hot and
pretty and awesome and good hard and big
hard and you know nice skin and nice
hair and nice face
you know nice neck I mean she had a neck
bra she had a neck I mean they'd have
you know something I mean even here
giraffes you know two countries over
[ __ ] you know you could hear them
kind of leaning over listening what she
was up to cuz she had that type of neck
beautiful you know that beautiful top
[ __ ] piece that fifth appendage boy
that neck and she wasn't talking about
[ __ ] I don't know man um but I'll say
this dude that oh yeah when we broke
I remember driving across the country
and you know hiding on her porch and
petting somebody's cat that I didn't
know and so I definitely had some real
attachment issues you know homework so
check out this article by Psychology
Today called how your attachment style
impact see relationships check it out
and let me know thank you got a brother
will do man and we'll put that link how
your saw your let's listen to the end of
one more time impacts your relationship
how your attachment style impacts your
relationships will do we'll put the link
to that at the top of the episode links
in YouTube but thank you so much man
that attachment theory I think I really
have had some attachment issues onward
hey this is Alex from LA I just want to
play devil's advocate after your long
white conversation about mushrooms you
do have to remind some people that you
know jokes can still be dangerous I did
truman's for the first time and you know
I thought it was amazing
and it was amazing it was mind-blowing
life-changing started I started doing it
a little bit more my third time around
we put in a jungle book the new one and
if you're on Coons you know those those
[ __ ] animals you know they're real
they're real for sure and the snake taw
he like does that whole hypnosis thing
and he spun me out and I had like a full
seizure threw up everything like that
when I came to my girlfriend she was on
the phone with a 911
she said she she saw me died not she
thought I died that she saw me died well
look it sound like your girlfriend's
into some damn sorcery and [ __ ] if she's
seeing you dying you're not dead I'm
saying that's not good
I'm not saying it's a bad relationship
but no matter what I want a woman who
sees me alive no matter what you know
even if she you know how you know I want
to be one even if I'm at the funeral I
want her to secretly know that I'm
laying over there in a box
you know smoking a jewel or something a
creme brulee you know jewel cartridge
here's what I'm saying to that yeah you
might spin out your own mushroom
brother okay you're on mushrooms man
that's the but that's the Lord brain
diuretic
that shit'll make it leak out the back
of literally your brain you know what
kind of defrost your brain and takes all
the icicles out of you you know and just
let your meats cool naturally inside of
your head and if you're what you're
looking at electric snakes [ __ ] yeah
dude what do you expect you got done you
know you out there on the Lord's caviar
that mushrooms brah that snail bud or
whatever it is the Lord's caviar and you
[ __ ] uh you taking you getting
electrical watching electric snakes and
jungle book is a book and you taking it
in as a film man you know so out of the
gate you doing a lot of stuff you're
doing a lot of different types of stuff
that seems unnatural so yeah I think
mushrooms can be good for people because
here's what I've noticed from mushrooms
and I'm not on mushrooms but here's what
I've noticed for mushrooms is they you
know they a lot of times can save your
head is like a Internet and you have a
bunch of browsers open you didn't know
about it's like when you're looking at
pornography which I am 20 days clean of
right now boy bang bang so damn boy
sometime you know I'm feeling lively I'm
starting to notice more eroticism in
there you know they got these nipples
you can get off the internet you can put
them on your butt one on each but cheat
and you can feel your own butt and
pretend it's tits and so the future is
now that's what I'm saying who knows
what's next space travel who knows when
you got it you know when you got titties
in your pants bro that are your own so
it's your move ladies cuz we're making
moves ourselves you know what I'm saying
your move ladies but you got to be care
you can't be doing if you're looking at
electric snakes and you're spinning out
than this if you're Y if you're looking
at John something called Jungle Book and
it's a movie then you're making choices
you shouldn't be making man I'm thinking
also what the [ __ ] do I know bruh
onward thank you it is Michael from
Columbus Ohio hey Michael
thank you for calling man I'll be there
at the end of January 6th and 7th I
think and I'm looking forward to it
onward reason I'm calling is that for
weeks and weeks now something that you
said to Jordan Peterson has been like a
rattling around in my head and it's when
you told him about how you and your mom
had never laughed together and I don't
know I but you know I just been thinking
about that's was so long I figured I
should just call and tell you what I was
thinking well thank you for calling I
appreciate it yeah I felt pretty honored
to interview mr. Jordan Peterson because
he's you know just so smart almond
basically uh you know that it's not too
late and I had an idea for you
maybe you could use this podcast as a
way to to Dallas area like said you know
you sit down with comics and all these
other people for an interview with them
to talk why not you bring the
microphones back home for the holidays
and just for fun see if you could sit
down with her and record you know and I
always hear you guys just talking and
shooting the breeze reminiscing about
old times maybe something good will come
of it I think would be great to do that
with your brother - I think people would
love to hear it but you know if you
record it and you decide you don't want
to put it out and that would be fine too
but might be fun experiment for you and
anyway you know you come to Columbus
can't wait to see you and I wish you all
the best and thank it as a sweet message
you know and I thought about that I
think I would like to have my mother
come in here and come on the podcast at
some point you know I want to make sure
that you know I'm in a place where I
feel comfortable with that and then I
would have to make sure that my mother
feels okay comfortable with that and I
appreciate your sentiment you know
because I think you're coming from a
place where
yeah I mean I didn't realize that either
till I said that my mother and I have
never laughed together you know and and
I didn't realize that until I'd said it
you know so you know it's just crazy man
this all of this has been such a
learning man I thought uh I thought I
was done learning when I was a kid you
know but thank you and I've had thought
about having my brother on and I can't
decide maybe we'll do something in Baton
Rouge I won't see my mother during the
holidays because she moved out too she
uh she moved out to Arizona again but
but at some point and those are things
that are in my mind that I would like to
have them on and also I think about
guests I just want to have guests on
that like you know people email me a lot
about having just regular people on and
stuff like that and so I want to
experiment with some of that in the new
year you know uh you know I want to do a
you know I want to try some new stuff so
I appreciate you guys being here and as
always give me your honest feedback man
you can put it on the youtube you know I
don't read that but the but sometimes I
will dip in there the first few things
in common or something to see if
anybody's having a tough time or but our
producer our producer does and so if you
have constructive criticisms as always
you can leave those thank you so much
let's take one more call here we go hey
Colin from Jersey I just want to say a
pretty big fan I enjoy your podcast I
enjoy what you're doing I think you're
one of the most funniest most folks out
here I just wanted to say I got a little
issue going on thank you Chris for the
nice words man you know I don't think
I'm a good podcaster but I think that um
I do think that I am a good comedian
you know and I say that just because
I've done it for so long and I really
you know I know that I want to bring
something to you that you paid for that
is a good product and that's why I get
act out you know I act out if people are
being wild in the crowd because just to
me there's too much work is going into
making it a fun evening you know and
making it a time that's enjoyable
homeward me and my girlfriend are gonna
go on a date she said most of the times
that there's no chance of us getting
back together and I'm gonna read up
attachment Theory dude
onward so I'm trying to get rid of that
thought in my head a bit ever happening
so I'm just curious going on the date or
you know just hanging out or trying to
be friends is beneficial at all or do
you think that going cold turkey is the
best way but again feel appreciate
everything man you're your true true
comedian you're hilarious and just keep
up the good work man I come out to the
East Coast one of these days both I
definitely pull up show some love Gang
Gang brother thank you for that dude
Gang Gang yeah the thing is this if you
go with the next man do my my ex that I
wrote out there you know I tracked this
girl on the South Carolina dude I
remember one time I drove to I jumped
out of a you know we ate ate some
mushrooms and went to see string cheese
or somebody I jumped out of a moving
vehicle to see her in Tuscaloosa you
know and I wasn't a stunt person I was
just a [ __ ] you know a 24 year old
high on [ __ ] dope but um you know I
remember one time I stayed up all night
making her a little boat of me and her
like in a little French boat out of some
construction paper and marbles and [ __ ]
and it got heavy because I use too many
marbles this ended up being like about a
three pound boat and I took that to her
and we talked and then we got in a fight
outside of the car and she not a
physical disability shion's
and she set it on top of the car when
she was leaving or while we were talking
and she drove off and the whole [ __ ]
boat fell off the you know off the
there's some you know little wah Corsica
she was driving a little Corsica and you
know and I'd spent all night doing that
boat making that little [ __ ] with the
little oars and all the French [ __ ] and
but the thing is what I'm saying is I
showed up with a lot of expectations and
none of them were it's not that she
didn't respect him as I said she
couldn't she couldn't meet me there you
know I was still in love I was still
really struggling and she couldn't be
that for me and so there was nothing
that was going to come out good of that
meeting so I think you have to ask
yourself are you really ready for that
or are you gonna have a look in your
eyes the whole time like you still want
to get back together are you gonna be
trying to you know reach through that
electric fence you know what I'm sayin
bruh that barn why trying to get that
little new T or are you gonna be able to
be behaved and just be a friend because
if you can't I think maybe you just wait
because you just don't want to get your
own hopes up too much you know because
your hopes that have to come down
sometimes if you lift them sometimes
they have to come down so you just want
to be but you would want you under
monitor you want to keep them up but you
don't want to push them way up too high
sometimes because you're gonna have to
also be there to hold them as they come
down and it can be sometimes kind of
heavy on your spirit the but you know
it's tough man it's tough to still love
somebody and to be separate from them
you know and I'm you know I'll go
through stuff like that and uh you know
it's really tough you know it's really
really really tough man and I've been
struggling with a lot of that omona life
you know being in love you know loving
someone but you know being separate you
know and uh I don't know man more will
be revealed I think you know and the
good thing is though now this is a great
time here to just be a friend maybe you
get her a couple little hitters you know
maybe you put a jingle bell and a
shotgun and shoot it into her cheek nope
that's a joke bro that's a joke dude
so that's just a joke and that's
something that happens to people's
huncles who go looking in the gift
closet man let's get let's get out here
on a high note man thank you guys for
the calls this week I went through a lot
of them we tried the podcast on a
Tuesday on a Monday that might be
something I flirt with in the future I
just don't I feel amped up when I get
home from being on the road and so I've
been coming in on Sunday I'm trying to
get the pot out on Sunday night and man
it's just it's hectic and I want to make
sure I give you guys the best product
but right now I'm gonna jump off the
line just remember this is a good time
of year to be supportive and a love
somebody and a hug someone and take care
of yourself and to take care of others
you know this is a really good time of
year for that you know this is a good
time of year and I hope that I'm able to
do stuff like that and just you know not
think about myself and just I can just
be okay and have some [ __ ] fun you
know you feel me thank you everybody
that came out in Lexington bells will be
ringing we came in with a little bit of
music it was Christmas time I'm going
out with a little bit of spirit of
Christmas by Magnus ring Blum thank you
guys so much
be good to yourselves man you deserve it
and it's and be good to someone else too
you know even if they don't deserve it
you know see what happens their homework
[Music]
and I want to thank we have a young lady
made of some beautiful on the YouTube
you can see them beautiful new
accoutrements at the front of each
episode to represent the seasons what's
going on and I was sweet of her
and what any what a year it's been thank
you guys so much for being a part of
this year with me king in the sting were
taping the first episode the the trial
episode tomorrow we're still in trial
but we're excited and at it right now
happy holidays
[Music]
hi rebelling pants bro you fill in the
jingle and a gang